[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten wild ich habe bereits vor
längerer zeit mal eine leckere raphael
orte gemacht und euch dann versprochen
dass ich eine schokotorte macht und
jetzt habe ich so ein bisschen herum
experimentiert und irgendwie kam dann
eine große torte dabei raus weise so
lecker schokolade ich war deswegen
gibt's heute die roche torte hat die
große torte werde ich natürlich auch mal
machen wir werden jetzt erstmal den biss
gezeigt zubereiten und dafür zeige ich
euch mal die zutaten ganz schnell bevor
die familie rocher kombiniert weg ist
und zwar brauchen wir sechs eier 200
gramm zucker 120 gramm mehl 65 g
speisestärke 40 gramm back also da ich
nicht gelöst einen halben teelöffel zimt
eine prise salz und einen teelöffel
backpulver und hier habe ich 80 gramm
gemahlene und in der pfanne gerüstete
hatte risse die habe ich jetzt abkühlen
lassen und jetzt starten wir direkt mit
dem teig und die samira darf mir kurz
helfen warte ich will das cover darf man
die erde einschlagen
[Musik]
so kann stück besser als der papa da
haben wir einfach da rein so habe ich
gehört
[Musik]
10.000 euro schon jetzt noch einmal
gleich untersuche mein gott
nebst verschließt die eier trennen du
sollst du nicht die eier trennen
und jetzt gebe ich da den zucker mit
rein und lass das ganze richtig schön
schaumig und cremig rühren
und die einer creme ist fertig wenn sie
einfach schön schaumig und fast steif
ist das hat jetzt bei mir ungefähr fünf
minuten gedauert und samira hat es sich
in der zeit im schlafzimmer versteckt
und noch weitere roche kugeln zu
vernaschen ärzte gefunden
so jetzt geht es weiter mit den
trockenen zutaten genau die werden bei
zweien gegeben und einmal durchgesetzt
damit wir keine klümpchen haben vergeben
jetzt kakaopulver der speisestärke clubs
[Musik]
und jetzt wird es gesiebt
natürlich
und den rest kann man mit den fingern
durch streiten
jetzt kommen da auch die haselnüsse rein
und ich habe auch hier noch ein bisschen
kurzer schock das heißt die habe ich
vorhin vergessen zu erwähnen das sind
etwa 40 gramm
die habe ich schmelzen lassen gibt die
aber erst zum schluss mit aktien jetzt
wird es hier kurz unter gewogen ganz
leicht damit nicht das volumen von bis
zu tal kraus geht das kann ich ja du
kannst mir helfen ganz gehen noch nicht
kaputt machen lassen was ihnen und wenn
das mehl dann fast ganz untergehoben ist
geben wir noch die butter dazu die darf
jetzt natürlich nicht mehr so heiß sein
das muss mal wieder da oben heben
[Musik]
es reicht schon wir wollen ja den teig
nicht mehr kaputt röhren und die luft
raus schlagen und ich habe jetzt hier
bereits in den bug rahmen vorbereitet
den habe ich auf 26 cm eingestellt und
habe ein backpapier darunter gegeben
damit nichts ausläuft
und jetzt fühle ich da den teig ganz
vorsichtig herein
kann sein dass da am boden ab und zu
noch ein bisschen mehl hängt das einfach
nur mal kurz berühren
hier ist das ganze nur noch ein bisschen
verstreichen
und jetzt kann der teig bei ober und
unterhitze bei etwa 170° für 35 minuten
gebacken werden wir müssen auf jeden
fall die stäbchen poke machen und nach
dem backen zeitgleichen wer in unser tag
noch packt werden wir schon mal die
creme vorbereiten weil die auch kühl
gestellt werden muss und dafür brauchen
wir 400 milliliter sahne die ist jetzt
ganz kalt stelle ich auch gleich wieder
kalt hier habe ich 150 gramm zarter
schokolade und habe sie bereits
geschmolzen und sie ist leicht abgekühlt
hier sind 100 gramm haselnüsse die sind
bereits gerüstet
und hier habe ich 50 gramm puderzucker
und hier sind sechs teelöffel seiner
partei und zwar kann man da auch
sahnesteif leben aber ich nehme jetzt
dieses seiner tat weil man damit die
creme dann sofort weiter verwenden kann
und ihr fragt mich ja immer wie ich
meine teelöffel benutzer und wie groß
die sind und ich nehme da einfach immer
ganz gern solchem esslöffel weil die
immer die gleiche größe haben und
einfach einheitlich sind
zuerst müssen wir jetzt die haselnüsse
mit dem puderzucker ganz fein mahlen
du darfst mir helfen
[Musik]
ja ich gebe dir das kurz und wir
vermahlen jetzt die haselnüsse mit dem
puderzucker damit sie schön feiern
werden
hier sieht man jetzt auch das richtig
schön geworden ist jetzt kommt die
schokolade mit rein
seine nase weg
[Musik]
und es bietet sie einfach auch noch mal
kurz vermixt jetzt fühlen wir das hier
einfach kurzum da kannst du das ist
praktisch wie sir karan lukas
und jetzt stelle ich die nuss nougat
masse und die sahne noch mal kalt warte
noch schnell auf meinen tag besser
fertig ist und dann können wir die torte
auch mal zusammensetzen
der kuchen ist jetzt schön gebacken und
ich werde ihn jetzt noch heiß aus der
form lösen das geht am besten mit seinem
tortenring messer kann man einfach am
rand entlang fahren und dann den ring
entfernt
und ich werde ihn jetzt auch ein
geschirrtuch stürzen und das geht am
besten wenn ihr da so eine tortenplatte
mit dazu nimmt
[Musik]
das wertpapier abzählen und jetzt werde
ich ihn einfach abdecken und komplett
auskühlen lassen wie sich ihnen dann
weiter verwenden
der teig ist jetzt komplett abgekühlt
und ich werde ihn jetzt zweimal
durchschneiden und macht es einfach mit
so einer torten säge habt ihr so
eingestellt dass ich ungefähr drei
gleichmäßige böden habe und mit der
klappt es auch echt gut wetter einfach
durch und am besten klappt wenn der biss
wird schon einen tag alt ist aber ich
verwende jetzt einfach frisch weiter es
nur vollständig abgekühlt
ich habe was altes mauerwerk marines
säge
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich den boden auch schon
hier draufsetzen und wegsehen und jetzt
habe ich die zwei oberen böden einfach
noch mal weg
und wenn der biss mit schon einen tag
alt ist dann bröselt er auch nicht mehr
so arg das setzt sich jetzt einen
tortenring aus dem und damit meine
platte gleichen schmutzig wird gebe ich
da noch so parag papierstreifen darunter
dann bleibt die platte schön sauber und
ich muss dir danach nicht noch mal
säubern
[Musik]
und ich habe jetzt hier in der
flüssigkeit vorbereitet ihr könnt jetzt
einfach irgendwas nehmen zum tränken der
böden dann werden die nämlich ein
bisschen saftiger ihr könnt zum beispiel
kaffee nehmen oder einen likör oder
irgendwas was euch am besten schmecken
saft geht auch ganz gut und damit drängt
ihr dann einfach die böden mit einem
pinsel
das waren so ungefähr 50 milliliter und
jetzt habe ich ein drittel davon benutzt
stellt den kuchen kurz zur seite und
welche creme aufschlagen und jetzt
nämlich diese schokolade und gibst ihnen
hohes gefäß das könnt ihr natürlich
jetzt auch in der küchenmaschine machen
aber ich mach das jetzt kurz mit dem
handmixer gerät ja ein g schnell da gebe
ich ein bisschen sahne dazu
[Musik]
das verwöhnen wir jetzt kurz auf
niedrigster stufe und dann gebe ich
jetzt noch die restliche sahne dazu und
auch gleich das salat zum steifen und
kann dann auch auf mich
und jetzt sieht man auch hier die creme
wird richtig schön fest und ich gebe es
die hälfte der creme auf den ersten
boden verteilt ist ganz kurz
dann gehen wir jetzt den zweiten boden
drauf trinken wir treten
jetzt kommt die restliche creme drauf
ihr dürft euch jetzt nicht wundern die
sie zwei christlich aus aber das hindert
die haselnüsse die hinter creme sind
weil man dafür seine nicht so abkühlen
nein damit sie nicht christlich wird
aber hier in der creme sind es einfach
die hasler die kasse mich aussehen ein
bisschen streichen oder streicheln
natürlich sorgt rücken genau dann den
deckel drauf kommt dass mir helfen nicht
sagt rückruf nicht so an
und jetzt kommt dann noch die restliche
flüssigkeit mit
die torte stellen wir jetzt kurz kalt
ich habe jetzt für den überzug damit wir
die torte noch ein bisschen dekorieren
können noch mehr andere creme wer aber
nicht so viel arbeit haben möchte kann
auch einfach diese creme benutzen und
einfach zum beispiel und drittel der
zutaten mehr nehmen und damit auch die
torte außen einstreichen aber ich will
dass der außen schön glatt wird und
deswegen machen wir gleich noch das
zweite springen zum schluss brauchen wir
noch ein paar zutaten für die creme die
ich jetzt ausruhen streichen werde und
für die deko ich habe jetzt 480 gramm
nutella und hab da auch eine prise salz
dabei es sieht ein bisschen komisch aus
dem keller und sagen ihr könnt natürlich
er mit einem snowboard kurden news
nougat creme nehmen
hier habe ich noch 50 gramm peter kober
türe und habt ihr geschmolzen
hier sind 100 gramm mascarpone und ich
brauche natürlich roche kugeln und für
den rand der torte ein paar haselnüsse
die werde ich gleich noch rösten und das
sind jetzt 200 gramm
ich werde jetzt aber erstmal die creme
vorbereiten und gebe jetzt die drei
zutaten einfach in meine schüsse rein
oder meine vier besser gesagt ich habe
eine prise salz dabei
[Musik]
und dann wird es einfach kurz verrührt
fertig genau das abschmecken mit nutella
und ich hole jetzt kurz meine torte
nehme ich den tortenring ab und erzählt
es klappt auch wunderbar
und jetzt kann ich den torten rand
einfach mit dieser creme bestreichen und
natürlich auch die oberfläche der torte
[Musik]
das muss jetzt auch nicht ganz glatt
sein weil ja jetzt da gleichnisse drauf
kommen und ich werde das hier das blatt
papier wegziehen und jetzt stelle ich
den kuchen ganz kurz kühl bereit die
nüsse vor
dann kann man es gleich geschafft ich
habe jetzt hier die netze bereits in
einer pfanne geröstet und zwar einfach
ohne öl und sie sind fertig wenn sie
anfangen lecker zu duften schalte ich
mal aus und da werden sich jetzt auch da
wird sich jetzt auch die haut entfernen
also man kann es einfach zwischen den
händen so ein bisschen reiben und dann
geht er so ein bisschen die schale weg
ihr könnt euch zum beispiel wenn eure
arbeitsfläche kalt ist können dass es
euch auf die arbeitsfläche gießen
schicken
[Applaus]
denn dann werden die nüsse ganz schnell
kalt und wir können sie dann so ein
bisschen hacken
dann nehmt euch einfach ein messer und
haken sie ganz hoch wir wollen auch dass
die jetzt hier grob bleiben damit der
torten rand dadurch etwas interessant
aussieht
ich nehme die abgekühlten nüsse und
besser ist einfach an den rand der torte
drücken
und weil die ja so groß gestückelt sind
wird auch jetzt nicht der komplette hand
verdeckt sein aber das muss auch nicht
sein
[Musik]
genau dieser pakt schon mal den kumpeln
aus
jetzt könnt ihr euch gerne noch die
torten stückchen markieren ich mache das
jetzt einfach mit so einem torten
einteiler einmal drauflegen und
markieren
ich mag ihr jetzt zwölf stücke und
moment genau und jetzt kommt immer eine
roche legt google hier an den rand jetzt
nehme ich mir noch mal so einen des
hering und stelle denn hier in die mitte
und da könnte jetzt zum beispiel noch
gehackte nüsse reingeben misst er nicht
aber ich finde das sieht dann noch mal
ein bisschen schöner aus kleiner tropfen
bringen oder mal streits einfach mit der
hand auf
das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder
aufgesprungen wir haben datenabfluss vor
[Musik]
so und dann ist die große torte fertig
stellen sie jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
kühl diesem ihrer verschönert sind
nochmal ich stelle es jetzt noch mal
ganz kurz kühl weiß hier drin sehr warm
ist und dann werden wir sie gleich
anschneiden ich habe jetzt hier bereits
eine angeschnittene torte ich habe die
torte schon am wochenende gemacht und
hab euch dann im bild bei instagram
gepostet und weil ich das rezept so gut
gefahren und hab ich jetzt heute noch
mal gebacken und gemacht aber ich
schneide jetzt einfach hier im stück weg
weil die torte schon schön abgekühlt ist
wie immer bewerben sie schon leute auf
dein handy haben über youtube
angesprungen
möchten sie bei der arbeit leider müssen
sie auch arbeiten wir für mich nur die
ist ich muss sagen das könnte darauf
dass schon genug moschee kuppel gegessen
so papa kriegt jetzt noch einen löffel
[Musik]
genauso ist immer erste papa und mama
und dann wie samir war
solange man nicht in der reihenfolge
duschen müssen jetzt probiert also
erkennt ja eigentlich schon vom
wochenende
ich bin dort auch richtig lecker vor
allen dingen hebt die auch so zwei drei
tage weil ja das ist eine leckere creme
ist ohne oder sowas und die kann dann
richtig schön durch sehen und das rezept
gibt es dann zum nachlesen auf sallys -
blog.de ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
beim nachbacken die tatorte sind auch
ganz bald folgen und die samira ist auch
der roche kugeln und wir sehen uns dann
einfach beim nächsten mal wieder wissen
wir lassen die drauf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und alle produkte die ich benutzt habt
findet ihr unten in der infobox da wo
info steht da verlinke ich euch alle und
jetzt im anschluss verlinke ich euch
noch ein leckeres rezept welches ihr
euch anschauen könnt